hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to state of decay okay
we just got the medicine which means
that Ed is probably still gonna turn
into his BAM [ __ ] I just decided to
slam that door but probably still means
that Eddie's gonna turn into a zombie
how's it going over here little buddy
how's it goin you want to come with me
on a on an adventure I haven't earned
this what is him what are we talking
about am I gonna be able to have options
for everyone in there like hey baby
wanna bunk with me - no I haven't earned
it I haven't earned it okay so I guess I
got to make up my own objective now
because after Lilly sent me on up
through a style hello Sam oh I didn't
see you at service last time you didn't
see anybody at service last Sunday will
nobody goes to those things because the
rest of us are too busy trying to stay
alive what you and Lilly and the rest do
a good job seeing to the needs of the
body uh-huh the way I see it it's my job
to see to the needs of our souls okay by
sitting in an empty room with a Bible
somebody will show up that's pretty Oh
I was all I was supposed to do that okay
spin sitting in an empty shelter with a
pot of soup uh okay so hungry person
showed up yeah well that was different
how so I'm not sure what they're talking
about but anyway Lilly Lilly can
accompany me right now cuz you refusal
okay you know what I'm just gonna go off
on my own I don't know what I'm supposed
to do ever do I have like a Questers
hurt tired tired I am a little bit at
loss here vailable active ooh I can
upgrade that's so cool you know what I'm
just gonna go out on my own and see what
it would sort rubble I can get BAM I
guess I'm gonna do without with
everything right now I'm just gonna go
out and about and see what the world has
for me maybe go for a nice yog in the
middle of the Zambia bar that is very
pretty I don't know what engine this
game is made on by the way oh hello I
hope you're a zombie
cuz you're about
to get rights bloated
Alan is sat Alan is sad what am I
supposed to do about that
oh I'm a minimap this building is a huge
blood oh that's probably why couple
kicks cardio and one in two and one and
that is not a good sign
I'm gonna go this way a lot not that way
why do you go that way zombies well
they're frolicking me oh my god they're
skipping it's terrifying
get off of my ass I can't use a gun cuz
what is wrong with you man what is
wonderful good
we're probably the head this is Wes all
right I got it oh no oh no I better done
hey yeah I want to use my gun ma'am
there we go BAM can't see you BAM there
we go
I literally can't see what is with these
bushes BAM there we go you go BAM
finally that did not go well I think I
need to go back
Oh use me pardon me hi there how are you
doing I'm gonna go back and see if I
can't like talk with someone or get a
class tour something
BAM okay I I really everything BAM
I really don't know cuz I mean it's kind
of I'm just wandering around here doing
mmm hello good to see you oh you're
tired okay that's right it's so much
shooting you're tired you're sleeping
Lily doesn't want to talk with me
because she betrayed me and I'm alright
you know what I am just gonna go out of
my own but before I do that I'm gonna
take a vehicle with me not the pizza car
this giant truck seems useful I hope
they all play don't ever have to get gas
oh no is the Sun going down I'm gonna be
in trouble I'm gonna be maybe there was
like a objective that popped up but I
sure didn't see anything
wait there's a green thing on my thing
this is there's a green thing on my
thing did I go see a doctor about it you
could go stupid jokes worst jokes ever
whoo okay all right all right are they
really just like here hi so look we're
not doing that great here uh-huh
you seemed average [ __ ] together so we
were hoping you'd let us thrown up with
your group this lady's name is Abigail
baby
hello baby
how you doing baby let's see
coward love sports uh you should join us
he just saved our lives you're welcome
baby sir
come with me wave of ladies up up whoa
all right I what I guard them all I need
to are now zom zoms coming in ah dude uh
me clipped right through the car man
these zombies ain't normal
they're super zombies he's nakorn me um
Wow laughs you stay down BAM things
aren't all bad um excuse me I know you
haven't been outside from your house in
a while but things are quite bad
actually
oh ah all right get on the freakin car
you [ __ ]
get in the car I'm gonna run you over if
you don't get in this damn car thank you
very much and drifting in a truck
not really everyone saw that zombie
horde alert what in the world is that
you gotta move here okay it's all we
need
you're welcome you're welcome baby okay
what is a zombie horde alert mean and
what do I need to do about that excuse
me uh Maya uh uh IIIi I thank you
finally good scuse me I was coming up
there to talk I'm not sure uh [ __ ] at
this rate I'd settle for a slingshot
better luck finding ammo for it at least
what I don't know what's going on
oh they're trading out shifts for them
via the watch
that's awesome zombie ad ain't doing
nothin
I'm god I think I rolled I'm not sure
what happened I can't see anything
oh oh oh wow I'll go out at night scary
at night yeah let's go let's do it at
BAM um not that zombie horde
what do I uh what we need some more
sleeping space
people are already sharing beds and
shifts now I've brought up some basic
plans but we'll want to get on this in a
hurry people are already talking about
leaving okay we'll get it we'll get it
taken care of man whoa ma'am thank you
shooting levels - thank you very little
BAM I'll reload reload run ah good golly
what what is the slow motion come on
damn that takes a lot of my help okay so
I think that was the whole thing we need
to build oh my hello BAM No
Oh boom kaboom II thank you all right so
what we need to do is we need to find
building materials okay don't know what
that is
gah stick I got a stick can have a stick
and a Molotov cocktail holy hell alarm
clock food okay our got song I run this
home oh my oh I see there are certain
items that you collect in a rucksack and
then you have to come home okay that's
actually pretty cool I'm starting to get
the game guys I'm starting to get the
game this bag is heavy and I'm a baby
can you please call me in my bed baby
boom BAM Hill boom still got the boom
dude stop getting so tired I need to get
some meds or something
Kabam drop this off found like a boss
gum for no reason
oh you know stop stuffing things what is
that Oh codeine whoa they have Kody in
here don't mind if I don't I'm just
gonna put this away don't leave that I
don't even know firecrackers own a small
backpack gun ammo Twinkies wait I have
two backpacks why do I have two
backpacks um huh I'm tired I need to oh
that's probably why I need to sleep okay
okay okay okay Kay Kay I need to go
sleep cuz it is night and I am only one
man it's not like some games where it's
just like infinite can I sleep please
nicely please I'm tired but I want to go
to ok I guess I got him excuse me pardon
me okay so how do I build a sleeping
area something in here right medical
area how do I build a sleep area says
this what I need to do right um hey uh
uh-huh well how do I get bonuses um I'm
a little kid I miss something here did I
miss like uh I must have missed
something because I'm not nice build a
sleeping area but I don't know how I
don't even know if we have materials and
it's kind of nice and there's zombies
everywhere
I would love to sleep I'm just saying I
would love to sleep you don't have to
sleep but I would love to sleep what do
I do
why is there a back door to our place so
confused I am but I'm I'm I I don't
excuse me can I share a bed with you
baby I don't know don't be a stranger
don't be a stranger
oh I won't hey Gunther can I share a bed
with you or not build a barricade 100
like oh I see on the window I don't know
why I would need to but all right how do
I build a sleeping area seriously how I
am at a complete loss but don't know
we've got a chance to treat some Goods
okay what do we do that mission trade
barrels of fuel okay so I do need fuel
I'm seriously out of lost I I really
don't know what's going on here what
what I swear that barrel was moving wait
what I am so confused I I don't get it I
don't get it
you are what are you doing either barrel
of fuel feel like getting a little
mercantile
don't worry I'll haul the stuff and
handle the deal it just need you to
watch my back okay cool with that all
right what do you think let's do it
it's the only thing I can do apparently
so let's just do it there's not that not
it let's do this mission that comes
later baby
okay I like how I just start to take off
even though they're not really in the
car I don't care if you fall out Boop
there we go that one's good deader
anyway all right so this is like I'm
this is like the only mission that I've
actually had that I can do since it
seems to be very sporadic about giving
me actual missions and not giving me a
lot detail I would love to have a page
where I can see what my missions are but
this is the best I can do I guess
ah
we're not going in it whoa I still go
when I look at my map
I'm off-roading a bit I think why oh no
I was wrong
um I'm driving through the woods why am
i driving through the woods why is there
giant rocks everywhere why am i going
this way what am i doing where am I
going
can there be like a road or something oh
my what happened I don't even know how I
got a pit god damn it did I just I F
dust I have dust in the a I nope I guess
not
we're taking this sucker Oh God uh okay
and there we go we're still good I guess
why is this in the middle of a
random-ass field that doesn't sound good
poop I'm sorry weak oh that does sound
good whoop
I finally have a stick again god damn I
can't see a bloody thing who's a zombie
I better look around some more for what
there is ami right here we scoop them
hey deal great I think we'll all benefit
laughs you're so good about talking to
finance follow you all right let's roll
how are we supposed to get this giant
ass barrel on that
rich faster there's louder take it take
it baby
sit tight I've gotten this stuff home
alright let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go
I hope they can't pull me out of my own
car let's go let's go let's go
get off of my car get off please get off
please get off get off get off how do I
get you water
not like that get off my car yeah there
we go got it damn trees Oh pulling these
damn ass trees out in this damn ass
field God dingus okay finally found a
road I guess oh hello there ha oh and
the road has disappeared again I guess I
just have to go through the woods for
some reason oh boy oh oh oh come on come
on please please just work for me baby
please oh oh
what is with that sound like this it's
not like the stores here had the
greatest selection to begin okay I
pretty much switched to buying
everything
oh man support local business - once you
can order a toilet that's a rep Henry OH
- in the morning you don't go back what
I mean hypothetically not that I my
point is it's convenient
okay yeah yeah okay livery guy never
once tried to ah look I don't know what
warranted that conversation but I guess
I discovered a trade about you you like
to jabber on a bit hey God
dingus its guy saw flames this truck is
gonna explode isn't it at any minute
this truck is just gonna burst in a
giant fireball okay how do i oh oh oh no
oh no come on
please please do it for me please please
be nice please be nice where's the
where's the where is the hmm ah what did
I go I want excuse me what happened I
guess you could say I flipped out a bit
there okay anyway moving on just going
home I want to get these home and I want
to be done with this damn I'm tired
oh god no wonder um that did not sound
good good
can I sleep after this like pretty
please okay I'm free and clear see you
soon okay
thank you ma'am
boom we've got it all right cool
finally Thanks finally we're done don't
know how to build a sleeping area but at
least I'm home fashioned open doors Lily
you happy what I did you're welcome
you're welcome Lily Lily you're welcome
why are you all running around like
little idiots hey hey you hey hi hi oh I
got a drum found this
there you go what you got goodies no
enough oh you know oh my Kenny oh my
goodness there's zombies inside the fur
zombies are inside the perimeter that's
not a good thing
I should probably kill you guys what are
you doing ah tell me people okay you
know what I got
ah damn for me I'm gonna die
I've been bit worse than ed has Lily is
staying relaxed uh-huh yeah okay what I
mean when it comes to long-term survival
uh-huh
like I've got my dad's old notebooks and
I'm sure some people here have at least
worked on a farm
yeah oh do a whole lot more okay go on
well since we don't have the internet
anymore I'm thinking we should start
assembling a reference library Oh books
on gardening electrical engineering oh
oh hi
okay uh right okay I guess that's my
next mission but I'm think I'm done for
this part here this game actually is
quite interesting if a little bit wonky
at points is still fun I would recommend
playing it um I'm giving this a thorough
try I don't know if I'm gonna do any
more parts than this I meant playing on
my own a bit but I think I've given
enough a look for you guys so anyway
this has been stated okay if you really
want more let me know in the comments
but if you think this is enough you can
pick it up here so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next
by
oh dude dude dude dude there's a dude
does Danielle
you're dead oh don't even try it
haha no Dean tell me twice
aha find a kitchen
haha